we're continuing the legacy of the MCU
and we're going to do that in new ways
unexpected ways and really build on the
legacy of what's come before and what if
we're going to explore corners of the
universe that might be untouched which
is really exciting I am burdened with
glorious service one of the biggest
questions that audiences had coming out
of a game is where did Loki go this
series will answer that
anything about one division is that we
get to see what an ideal like for one
that vision actually looks like we're
gonna make the first scary MCU film
[Music]
welcome back everyone its charlie you
probably just saw the news Marvel
confirmed that the Loki series that's
happening during Marvel phase four will
cross over wit Doctor Strange - just
like the Scarlet Witch series is going
to crossover with Doctor Strange -
they've released a couple details about
how that's going to work so we'll break
it down we're still doing the Infinity
Saga box set giveaway - all you have to
do to enter that is be a subscriber and
leave your best theory about Loki during
Doctor Strange to everyone queue up that
clip of Loki versus Doctor Strange from
Thor Ragnarok now keep in mind that Loki
with the tesseract is a different
version of the character but I have a
feeling that they're going to try and
pay off that funny moment in a much
bigger way I haven't fallen anything for
one minute you second rate so we'll just
break this down top 5 style starting
with number 5 Doctor Strange - is
scheduled to come out May 7 2021
we already know that the Scarlet Witch
series is gonna cross over and she'll be
a major character during dr. strange to
her Wanda vision Disney Plus series
doesn't have an exact release date yet
but on the timeline here they say it's
coming out before Doctor Strange - and
the plot of that is gonna set up what's
going on during Doctor Strange - now
there's no specific date for the Loki
series yet either but on the timeline
they're saying it comes out after Doctor
Strange - but still during the spring
and the end of the spring is defined as
June 20th it'll be six episodes just
like the one division series so doing
these super complicated math
calculations of subtracting six weeks
from June 20th that means that Loki
episode 1 will probably be released at
least by May 14th the week right after
Doctor Strange 2 hits theaters
approximately number 4 they're saying
Doctor Strange - we'll set up the Loki's
series and that Loki will at least have
a cameo in Doctor Strange - maybe even a
post-credits scene there's already so
much stuff that they had to set up for
Marvel phase 4 using dr. strange - and
typically there are only 2 to 3 post
credits
in most Marvel movies but there's no
rule that says that they always have to
do it that way
guardians of the galaxy volume 2 is the
exception they had five separate scenes
at the end of that movie
we know that the Loki series will follow
tesseract Loki from Avengers endgame and
based on what the writers have said in
the logic that they set up during
endgame when Loki stole the tesseract he
created an alternate timeline beginning
at this point in 2012 he was never
captured by the Avengers Thor never took
him back to Asgard in Chains to face
Odin's judgment and Tom Hiddleston says
that the last thing that this version of
Loki remembers as he's opening this
portal to escape is that he's just been
thrashed by the Hulk he's super pissed
off about it and part of the Loki series
will follow him as he tries to get his
revenge
so Doctor Strange to multiverse of
madness obviously were thinking more
about nightmare Scarlet Witch and Doctor
Strange
but also think about Loki causing havoc
with the multiverse and think about how
pissed off dr. strange would be if he
learned that Loki was doing that 3 the
actual plot synopsis of the Loki series
is him going all Doctor Who and quantum
leap using the tesseract space stone to
change the course of human history by
altering key events through our timeline
on this version of Earth like here in
this teaser image he shows up in New
York City in Times Square the weekend
that the first jaws movie was released
in theaters that was 1975 each of the
six episodes that will be him going to a
different event in world history causing
mischief
so obviously Doctor Strange does not
become Doctor Strange sorcerer supreme
till around 2016 like during Avengers
end game when Hulk goes to get the time
stone from the ancient one in 2012 she
said you're about five years too early
doctor Strange's a couple blocks that
way at the hospital performing surgery
right now so they haven't explained the
mechanics of time travel during the
Loki's series yet because right now he
only has the tesseract and as far as we
know it only has the ability to open
portals to other places in space not in
time as far as we know right now he'd
only be able to jump through time in
space if he also stole the time stone
from Doctor Strange that would make him
even more pissed off with Loki as far as
the director of Doctor Strange to his
said the basic plot idea is Doctor
Strange and now they've said Scarlet
Witch teaming up with him to stop
nightmare from taking over our dimension
driving everyone mad in ending
everything as you might have guessed it
nightmares by turning nightmares into
reality like he does in his own
dimension the reason why the director
was saying he wanted nightmare for the
sequel a couple years ago was he loved
the concept that nightmares were a
separate dimension you only touch them
when you were sleeping and the nightmare
character is one of the major fear lords
normally he's only able to influence
people through their dreams on a limited
basis because the barriers between
dimensions and the ancient one and now
Doctor Strange prevent him from entering
our dimension but early speculation
based on Scarlet Witch the reason he's
able to physically enter our dimension
might be because of the plot of The
Scarlet Witch series and her reality
warping powers ripping a tear in the
fabric of the multiverse that's how
powerful she is her power keeps growing
with each new movie or an out series
talking about one division but Loki
might also have something to do with
that too if he's responsible for the
multiverse going crazy
number two the whole concept of the
Wanda vision series is that they're
doing the Tom keen vision run for the
first half of the episodes and then the
second half the story turns into this
crazy huge action story more akin to
what you'd see in a big Avengers movie
in Tom King's vision run the roles are
swapped a little but it's vision the
main character who longs for a normal
life so he literally builds himself a
nuclear family a wife two children a dog
he becomes the Avengers consultant for
the US government living in Washington
DC they live in a suburban house nearby
he constructs the perfect looking 1950s
Norman Rockwell picture of family life
for himself but then it completely goes
off the rails and in The Scarlet Witch
one division series it's supposed to be
Scarlet Witch that there's all those
things for herself she wants a normal
life so badly she constructs that
reality for herself they're even casting
for what seems like the Wiccan and speed
characters her children from the comics
Kevin Feige and elizabeth Olsen also
implied that they would be doing the
classic Scarlet Witch vision run where
they actually did have children together
but because of the way those comics
played out in what seems like is
happening during the doctor strange tube
multiverse of madness movie it sounds
like things go completely off the rails
as she starts to lose her
grip on reality and if nightmare really
is gonna be the villain of Doctor
Strange - nightmare literally turns her
life that she creates for herself into a
waking nightmare it kind of sounds like
they're using a similar concept to
spider-man into the spider verse
remember kingpins searching the
multiverse for versions of his wife and
child that are similar to the ones that
he's lost she goes crazy the multiverse
spills into Miles Morales earth
sounds like something similar is gonna
happen to Scarlet Witch and that's where
Doctor Strange gets involved sensing
that the villain nightmare has used this
opportunity to cross into our dimension
and probably sensing what tesseract Loki
is doing messing with the multiverse as
well but number one like I say just a
low-key cameo in Doctor Strange -
they're not making it sound like he's
gonna be a main character or anything
like that they didn't say anything about
a Doctor Strange cameo in the Loki
series but they haven't announced the
full cast of the Loki series yet and if
you've noticed each of the Marvel series
that they've started shooting have a
bunch of other MCU movie actors in them
so expect bigger characters from the MCU
to appear during Loki and it's a pretty
safe bet that there'll be a version of
Chris Hemsworth
Thor the cameos during the series even
if he's not a main character because
before they confirmed Doctor Strange to
crossover I'd assume that the Loki
series would lead up into Thor for love
and thunder because that's coming out
November the same year is the Loki
series if you look at this schedule -
the reason why the Avengers what-if
series is releasing after Doctor Strange
- in the Loki series is because they're
using both of those movies in the series
to sit at the concept of the what-if
storyline like what if Loki had escaped
after the first Avengers movie how would
things have gone down had he stolen the
tesseract it's literally a what-if type
of story so first they do that then they
do the really crazy what-if stories like
what if Marvel Zombies or what if Ultron
had been able to use visions body in the
mine stone during Avengers age of Ultron
there'll be a what-if episode with an
alternate timeline for every single MCU
movie 23 episodes total including both
of the MCU spider-man films so post all
your theories for what the Loki cameo
scene in Doctor Strange 2 is going to be
in the new Black Widow trailer will be
coming in about 4 weeks of course I'll
make videos for that too
let me know if there's any special
Marvel videos that you want me to make
or big questions that you have about
Marvel phase 4 I'll probably leave the
Infinity Saga giveaway open until they
drop that black widow trailer everybody
click here for my breakdown of the
Avengers what-if trailer footage from
comic-con and click here for my
spider-man into the spider verse 2
teaser trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]